una amigdalectomía es la extirpación
quirúrgica de las amigdalas palatinas
dos estructuras ubicadas en ambos lados
de la parte posterior de la garganta
normalmente las amígdalas tienen la
función de evitar las infecciones al
ayudar en la destrucción de las
bacterias nocivas y otros gérmenes que
ingresan al organismo a través de la
nariz y boca las adenoides ubicadas
debajo y detrás del paladar blando
tienen una función similar Generalmente
las amígdalas se agrandan e inflaman
cuando combaten una infección esta
afección se denomina
amigdalitis la amigdalitis puede estar
relacionada con la fiebre el dolor de
garganta la deglución dolorosa y la
hinchazón de los ganglios linfáticos de
la parte frontal del
cuello se diagnostica más comúnmente en
los niños pero también se puede observar
en algunos adultos Aunque existe una
cantidad de indicaciones para la
amigdalectomía la más común es la
amigdalitis recurrente o
Crónica la inflamación Crónica de las
adenoides por lo general debido a
alergias puede provocar el bloqueo de
las trompas de usta aumentando el riesgo
de contraer infecciones del oído medio y
la pérdida auditiva relacionada una
adenoidectomía es la extirpación
quirúrgica de las adenoides Generalmente
las amigdalectomía y las adenoidectomía
se realizan al mismo tiempo cuando llega
al hospital para someterse al
procedimiento se le colocará una vía
intravenosa y es posible que se le
suministre un sedante para ayudarlo a
relajarse en la mayoría de los
procedimientos se utiliza anestesia
general por lo tanto estará dormido todo
el tiempo que dure la operación se
insertará temporalmente un tubo
respiratorio por la boca y en la
garganta para ayudarlo a respirar
durante la operación las ambialet comías
y las adenoidectomía pocas veces se
realizan con anestesia local en adultos
y y nunca en
niños durante la amigdalectomía el
cirujano utilizará un retractor especial
para mantener la boca del paciente
abierta y un depresor de lengua para
garantizar una vista despejada de las
amígdalas el cirujano sujetará una
amígdala por vez con los forceps de
amígdalas la desprenderá del tejido que
la
rodea y la extirpar con un lazo
corredizo o una pinza prensora de
amígdala
la electrocauterización o las pinzas y
los lazos detendrán cualquier sangrado
que se produzca en la zona donde se
extirparon las amígdalas Generalmente
esta área cicatriza naturalmente sin
puntos el procedimiento para una
adenoidectomía es muy similar al de una
amigdalectomía Por lo general ambos
procedimientos se pueden realizar en 20
a 60
minutos después de la operación se lo
llevará a una sala de recuperación hasta
que se desaparezcan los efectos de la
anest
lo que por lo general tarda entre 8 y 10
horas es normal que los pacientes de una
amigdalectomía regresen a su hogar el
mismo día del
procedimiento